when do you become a collector when you
have more than two or more than one or
more than three is it more than three
that I'm barely a collective hi I'm
Keanu Reeves co-founder of arch
motorcycle let's take a look where I
grew up in Toronto every summer
motorcycle gangs would come into a place
called New York ville those bikes those
people those pirates
I think touched that ten-year-old kid in
a way I learned how to ride a motorcycle
when I was doing a film in Munich this
young woman had an in Durham and I asked
her if she'd teach me how to ride it and
when I came back to Los Angeles this is
probably around 86 87 I got my first
motorcycle so this is where it all
happens
kind of backstage if you will we have
some client bikes here being worked on
and assembled and then personally this
is the second motorcycle I bought in Los
Angeles around 1987 it's a 1973 Marc - a
Norton commando had a lot of good times
with this motorcycle and I just grew up
really loving Norton's the upswept pipe
it's an English twin Norton was renowned
for the featherbed frame which means
that the engine is rubber mounted kind
of taking a lot of the vibration out of
it it's got a nice sound smells good
when it heats up the oil and got a lot
of miles on that motorcycle
[Music]
in films I wrote a motorcycle in chain
reaction and a film called My Own
Private Idaho in my own private Idaho
the gentlemen came out with a canary
yellow Norton and the guys like so do
you know this bike and well this is how
you know I was like I got it that was a
fun day
to ride that bike and ride with River
Phoenix what about John wick didn't you
read in that yeah so recently in John
wick Chapter three yeah I got onto the
bike so I had to write it down an
alleyway and yeah I did write it down a
bridge and there's a fight sequence yeah
I wrote in John League three Norton's
the year that I bought the 73 the shift
patterns on the other side of the
motorcycle in a different direction so
that took a second and then when it came
to the reality of the Norton it was
amazing you know it's not as super scary
fast you know especially for a young
rider you know I didn't get on a
motorcycle that's a hundred horsepower
and I can go 150 miles an hour on it I
can do that now but I've never gone 150
I'm actually mmm I haven't actually gone
that fast
I'm like another 135
[Music]
this is the Ducati that was in the
Matrix Reloaded spectacular bike
beautiful motorcycle Ducati did a
special green and kind of matrix green
which makes it kind of trick
it's got Matrix Reloaded on it carrie
anne moss roy who had never ridden a
motorcycle in her life learned how to
ride a Ducati nine nine eight the
motorcycle was with the rich house keys
who were the writers and directors of
the Matrix trilogy we have become
custodians of the motorcycle and it's
really cool to be able to show you this
bike we'll go through it and make sure
everything works and the next time we're
at the track I think we'll take it out
you know when I work or when I work on
films you know in the past they would
you know have contracts that said you
couldn't ride a motorcycle you know
you're in a set and they don't want you
to crash so I would sometimes I would
pay attention to that and sometimes I
didn't oops can't help it it's not
difficult to communicate what it's like
to ride a motorcycle because you know if
you've ridden a bicycle you kind of get
it and a motorcycle you're a little more
vulnerable so the stakes are higher
which I like for me it's the visceral
quality of it the vibration the wind the
sound and then it's just really a great
place to think to feel to get away you
know when I don't ride a motorcycle I'd
go through withdrawal it's not good for
my health
I had a harley-davidson a Dyna wide
glide which was an amazing motorcycle
and I was looking to personalize it and
then I was introduced to guard Hollinger
who owned a custom building company
called chop rods we ended up working
together and he ended up building a
custom bike he took the Harley engine
and then built a motorcycle around it
and that became the prototype for the
arch motorcycle so this is a 2019 kr GT
1 the company makes over 200 parts for
the motorcycle it's all billet aluminum
we manufacture those parts but we also
work with some high-end other companies
third-party so we have an öhlins
high-end front suspension south african
company called BST four carbon wheels
we're working with a great company out
of Wisconsin called S&S for the power
plant what else we got we've got some
michelin tires which are pretty awesome
we work with an italian company called
rhizoma signals mirrors foot controls we
also make the seat custom for the owner
so it's you know fitted see when you
start this thing
[Music]
it sound good they ride amazing so in
terms of the company definitely I'm
involved with the the dream of the
company the ambition of the company
I can't assemble a motorcycle and you
don't want me to fix it I can test ride
it and I can tell you what's wrong and I
can you know what quality control how do
we want it to feel what are we doing I'm
not doing any of the drawing guard is
doing that but he'll show me and we'll
you know talk about it and then
infrastructure and what's the voice of
the company what who are we what are we
presenting and I don't work with that so
if the KRG t1 is a performance cruiser
then this motorcycle is like a
performance cruiser sport what makes it
sport so the riding position instead of
having four controls we have a mid
control it has a different rake on the
1s it's brought in a little bit so
handling is a little different also
we're gonna have different wheels
obviously different bodywork so it's got
some other kind of developments going on
in terms of tank design we're still
working on our final exhaust system for
it and then there's a whole bunch of
other design elements that are going on
under here we have a new instrument
panel the frame is different than the
KRG t1 it's not exposed and what's going
on inside is a little bit different we
also like the two-track rides so there's
the ponies for when we want to go fast
on a racetrack I'm riding the zx10 here
the ninja guards got the r1 Ross who
works the company he's dealing with the
Aprilia and that might be Simon's really
amazing all of them amazing motorcycles
and it's really fun just to to get
together we do a lot of riding with
the arches and going arch events and
ride all through the Santa Monica
Mountains and and that's great
but we all love riding and if you're on
a track you don't have to worry about
traffic or speed limits yeah let's see
bikes that I have them written that
wouldn't mind well I mean of course the
Vincent Black Shadow and there's a
couple of examples those probably some
20s brough superiors I've never been on
a MotoGP modern MotoGP motorcycle that
might be kind of fun you know gotta be
insane oh my god anyway I've never
ridden one of those well if I get on a
brough in a Vincent Black Shadow and get
the chance to ride emoji MotoGP bike
that'd be pretty awesome
[Music]
what we have here is what we call the
method one four three
this is a prototype so you can't jump on
this yet and ride it it's it's kind of
like a how the automobile company does
concept cars this is kind of a concept
motorcycle that we're looking to make
into production it will eventually have
a carbon fiber monocoque frame you can
start to see the idea of that coming
down here on the down member of the
frame this will become carbon fiber the
powerplant is an S&S but it's gonna be
ridiculous it's a 143 cubic inches it's
a little futuristic we like the idea of
just how we're overlaying into
integrating different materials the
aluminum carbon fiber going into the
elements of the skins of the seat and
then just some of the design elements
are pretty spectacular BST is going to
be developing a new wheel for us it'll
be outrageous this motorcycle is
outrageous but that's part of the fun
[Music]
advice to a new rider
I mean if you're in the kid and your
legs starting off with a little minibike
I mean that's you're gonna people are
gonna show you what to do if you're a
young adult and you're not dirt riding
and you want to get on the street take a
class you know start with a small CC get
a bike that you can get your feet on the
ground something that's not gonna freak
you out you know if you're not gonna do
all of that just don't go crazy like if
you're have never ridden a motorcycle
don't get you know a sport bike that's
got a lot of horsepower but yeah be
comfortable on it don't get too much
power that you know it can overwhelm you
too quickly and have fun